hi there steve kaufman
today i want to talk about
which language is the best language or
which languages are the best languages
uh people often ask me
uh you know should i learn this language
or that language
uh
and but what really triggered this video
was
uh i'm sort of getting tired of having
russians come on
here commenting on my youtube channel or
in
in twitter
and telling me in all seriousness that
ukrainian is just some kind of a funny
dialect of russian
uh when russians hear ukrainian it
sounds funny
uh ukrainians uh can't really i mean
these are actual quotes ukrainians the
language doesn't really exist they can't
really communicate with each other
ukrainian they speak russian to each
other and on and on
um
my experience has been that ukrainian is
very much a language on its own
uh vocabulary more similar to polish
if anything
if i look at polish now that i've
started polish if i look at polish
ukrainian czech and russian
in terms of vocabulary the
russian is the outlier
which doesn't matter i mean each
language developed has its own history
and so forth and so on that those
languages and the belarus and probably
the south slavic languages were all part
of a
original
you know proto-slavic language at some
point or even before that in a
proto-european language sure so what
uh to my mind the answer what is the
best language they're all equally good
definitely
and um they're equally good at
expressing
things they do it in different ways
but you hear a lot of this sort of
you know french is precise the japanese
is vague
but
if japanese person wants to be precise
they can be precise they may take a few
more words
to do so uh but they can achieve it i
have you know i speak a lot of languages
i've often been in a situation of
interpreting i have never and this is
interpreting from chinese to english to
french japanese whatever i have never
found that i'm not able to express
a certain thought in another language
all languages work
and
the number of speakers again i don't
want to pick on the russians but i was
telling some russians that i was
learning czech and so why would they
reaction why would you possibly learn
czech there's only 10 million people and
it's you know insignificant that you
know our russian language is one of the
greatest languages and all this kind of
stuff it's not it's just one language
and so is czech and so is finnish and so
is the language spoken by the inuit
and spoken by the uh
i don't know some tribe in the jungle
um
languages have different evolutions it
may be that the
total amount of say literature produced
in one language is greater than produced
in another language
fine
some of the great works
creative works were never written down
you know the works of homer
uh were part of an oral tradition for
centuries the ramayana epic
in india and southeast asia
which is very popular today was just
a story that was told by people i'm sure
that the
the inuit in the far north and the
and
people wherever you find them
who
have oral traditions and haven't yet
written things down will all have
wonderful
works of literature
i've heard i have no indirect experience
that
the languages of the native indians in
north america are very complex they're
not sort of simple because those people
haven't built you know
castles and cities and
all of the
sorts of things that we identify with
quote civilization uh they had a
different lifestyle hunting lifestyle
whatever it doesn't mean that their
language is less complex less
capable of expressing things and so
forth at least insofar as the languages
that i have come across
uh every language that i learn
like now starting with polish
it's wonderful i enjoy it and
there's there's often prejudice against
certain languages like
well russians versus these are the
ukrainian for example or
uh chinese mandarin speakers who
consider you know cantonese like i was
in beijing once and
told them that i uh spoke uh cantonese
their term for cantonese they call it
nyoyu because to them the sounds sound
so like bird chirping whatever it might
be
people say that dutch is an ugly
language i haven't started dutch but
i'll tell you if i start learning dutch
i'm sure i'm going to enjoy it
some people say that danish you know
sounds like
people speaking with hot potatoes in
their mouth or something
um
i i love listening to danish and
i really enjoyed watching this movie
babette's feast if you're a language
lover you gotta watch it because there
you can hear swedish danish
and italian
and it's a lovely movie
uh
danish i love listening to danish
cantonese
i must say before i started it i thought
it didn't sound as nice as mandarin but
once i get into it
i enjoy it just as much so
you know to me there's no hierarchy of
of languages
they're all equally
uh valid equally beautiful equally
expressive
uh and the only thing that matters is
which one are you motivated to learn as
i said about accents which accent are
you motivated to imitate
uh language is just a means of
communication
uh there are no hierarchies i uh i'm
often amused by the sort of cultural
chauvinism that certain people seem to
express again the chinese we have five
thousand years of history no one no
chinese person has ever told me what was
that event five thousand years ago
from which they count their five
thousand years there was no event
nothing particularly important happened
five thousand years ago it's just
we have five thousand years of history
okay everybody has history the chinese
evolve one way i mean we all have a
common grandmother apparently some sixty
thousand years ago and we all evolved
our separate different ways
uh
and i must say i just find that any form
of cultural chauvinism
linguistic chauvinism
robs me the wrong way
yeah i enjoyed learning czech 10 million
people if i were to go after finnish
that's why i like moses mccormick like
he studies georgian and estonian and
i don't know hmong or some language from
southeast asia it's all part of that
human experience that we can explore
and i don't see any purpose in
trying to create hierarchies of better
or worse more important less important
more beautiful less beautiful more
expressive less expressive i haven't
found that to be the case at least with
the 15 or 16 languages that i have
either learned or tried to learn so
that's my take on the best language
in the world the best language to study
is the one you're most motivated to
learn
thank you for listening